la pension alimentaire
j'avais pensé en montant de 800 euros
par mois de quoi 10 ans des communes
aussi et ça fait 10 ans t'es dans la
merde antoine va saisir par carte des
invalides
il a c'est pas fini la foire qui se loge
qu'ils apprennent à se faire à manger en
quoi la dans la simple rôle qui donne un
sac n'avait bien beaux animaux monsieur
parce que je suis l'homme qui ne sait
rien faire des percées les battages en
mange plus que les chalutiers prompt à
bientôt alors au début on envie de vous
aider parce que vous êtes tellement
paumé mais quelques mois après nous ça
nous tombe sur la gueule parce que quoi
je ne sais pas ce que vous êtes
incapable de lire tout seuls et un recul
est en train de tisser une femme comme
alice mois la pensée trouver du
réconfort en font parler à ma soeur j'ai
fait ce qu'il m'a pris six levées à
trois qu'ils aient quitté appris à
parler comme ça c'est toi il faut que tu
trouve une solution parce qu'on a tous
des problèmes de pannes femmes c'est
très très bon c'est le secrétaire
quelqu'un qui semblaient accuser mais
toute la journée qu'ils devancent à 50
euros kg par mois ça demain p présent la
public numéro tout genre de fille c'est
quoi
consentante indect vraiment pas qu'on
perde face à lui par ses remarques
d'ouverture ça sa vie le web on regarde
entre avatar fait je crois que j'ai une
dernière à cannes
est ce que je me disais quand je la
regardais au tribunal me disait qu'il
était plus belle sans moi
j'aimerais au moins comprendre pourquoi
les particules heures essayez plutôt de
comprendre pourquoi le rester
l'ouvrier alice où tu as tout faire pour
la récupérer tu as un boulevard devant
toi
bon alors c'est qui le meilleur papa du
monde
cela